only on CTM this morning we've got a
first look at Kanye West's very
revealing new interview with David
Letterman the rapper details his
struggle with mental illness on the new
season of the Netflix show I love this
title my next guest needs no
introduction it's a topic that Kanye
rarely discusses Letterman asked him how
bipolar disorder affects his brain
define it for me what is the mechanism
that is malfunctioning or is taking a
break in your brain do you know I
wouldn't be able to explain that as much
just you know because I'm not a doctor I
can just tell you what I'm feeling at
the time and I feel a heightened
connection with the universe when I'm
ramping up it is a health issue this is
like a sprained brain like having a
sprained ankle and if someone has a
sprained ankle you're not gonna push on
him more right with us once our brain
gets to a point of spraining people do
everything to make it worse now Kanye
West says he is under a doctor's care
that he uses alternative treatment
methods but he thinks medication may
work for others with bipolar disorder or
dr. taryn new rule is with us now a lot
of people tear applauding him for
speaking out saying that it could
certainly help others did you understand
what he was saying you agree with what
he's saying
I am applauding him and every other
celebrity that comes out and talks about
their mental health illness because this
is a real struggle for so many Americans
one in five Americans our husbands our
children our friends are dealing with
this and many of them are suffering in
silence they're suffering with shame and
guilt they're suffering alone and
they're not getting the care and the
treatment that they need
and you can't cement oil you cannot and
that's the issue I think it's not a
tumor or a mass that you can see it's
not a plaque in a heart artery that I
can show you but the pain is real and
some have described the pain as being
worse than the most worse physical pain
you can possibly imagine how do you
identify it what are the typical system
it's a symptom start well bipolar is
based
a mood disorder that's characterized in
fluctuations in mood energy activity and
your ability to really function on a
daily basis and it swings between these
very high highs mania or hypomania and
these low lows are depression and it
affects about two and a half percent of
the American population it can be often
misdiagnosed for many years and when
it's not treated properly it can wreak
havoc on a patient or a person's
financial life their personal life their
work life and it can be an associated
with an increased risk of suicide we
know that about 10 to 15 percent of
bipolar patients die with suicide but
again Bravo to Konya you know I think
it's hard to explain it as he said what
it feels like did you bring a DeLorean
analogy I thought was very graphic and
interesting it was and I read something
last night that somebody wrote behind my
smile is a breaking heart behind my
laugh I'm falling apart behind my eyes
are tears at night and behind my body is
a soul trying to fight these are
warriors that are fighting it's very
lonely
we need to empathize and support them in
this country better than we do Sarah
thank you well put the new season of my
next guest needs no introduction with
David Letterman premieres tomorrow on
Netflix for names of mental health
providers you can call the mental health
services helpline at 1 800 662 help